شق فريق كرة السلة الوطني
اللبناني طريقه إلى نهائيات كأس الاتحاد
الدولي لكرة السلة في آسيا
هذا الأسبوع ، نشعر بسعادة كبيرة بعد
كتابة التاريخ لبلدنا ،
كما تعلم ، لقد قلته مرات عديدة أننا
أتينا من بلد محطم ، لذلك نريد فقط
أن  نسعد شعبنا
برؤية كل هؤلاء المعجبين اللبنانيين أه
يدعمونا بمشاهدة كل هذه الفيديوهات
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ومشاهدة الأطفال
يقفزون من مقاعدهم أه
والديهم يستمتعون بالألعاب معًا وهم
يستمتعون بالألعاب مع عائلاتهم
هو شرف لنا جميعًا الاتحاد الآسيوي لكرة القدم
تقام الكأس كل أربع سنوات
وتتكون من فرق عبر آسيا وأوقيانوسيا ،
وللوصول إلى النهائيات ،
خرج لبنان من الصين لأول
مرة على الإطلاق في البطولة
أفضل لاعب في كأس آسيا
للتغذية الراجعة من لماذا العراقي الآن
[موسيقى
] لبنان  فاز قائد فريق Cedars و
star Point Guard بجائزة أفضل لاعب في
البطولة ، إنه حلم منذ أن كنت
طفلاً
أن يُدعى أفضل لاعب في آسيا
للمشاركة معه  والأهم من
ذلك
كله أن مشاهدة جميع مشجعي الشرطة هؤلاء وهم
يصوتون لي ويدعموني ويدعموني بعد
كل مباراة هو نعمة على ما يرام
، كما أن انتصار فريقه يوفر
بصيص أمل في الأوقات العصيبة التي
كان الاقتصاد اللبناني في حالة من الانهيار
منذ عام 2019.  وصفه البنك الدولي بأنه
اكتئاب متعمد من قبل
النخبة الحاكمة في البلاد ،
لذلك عندما قدم رئيس وزراء البلاد
نجيب ماكاتي
تهنئته لفريق الأراكجي سريعًا بإسقاطه ،
أخبره أننا لسنا بحاجة إلى
تهنئته ونحاول ذلك.
نظيف أنه هو وزملاؤه السياسيون
وضعونا فيه ، لذا إذا كان بإمكانه إبقاء فمه
مغلقًا ، فسيكون من الأفضل أنه كتب في رسالة على
Facebook إلى رئيس الوزراء ،
لسنا بحاجة إليكم يا رفاق لركوب الموجة
عندما نكون سعداء.  يمكن أن تكون سعيدًا بدونك ،
لذا ابق بعيدًا ، فهناك الكثير من
الأشياء التي يجب أن تهتم بها يا رفاق
بخلاف مجرد تهنئتنا
والتهنئة على مباراة كرة السلة
في النهاية ، فقد خسر لبنان.  حقق البطولة
بفارق نقطتين فقط أمام أستراليا ولكن
بالنسبة لبلد يواجه صعوبات عبر
قارتين ، فإن خط الفريق إلى
النهائي هو نقطة فخر وطني
حيث تمكن من الوصول إلى
المركز الثاني في آسيا الآن
أه
يظهر أن لبنان لن يموت أبدًا
هناك  دائمًا الأشخاص الذين سيقاتلون من أجل
لبنان يقاتلون من أجل العلم اللبناني
بغض النظر عما يحدث ، لذلك أردنا أن
نكون الأمل لهؤلاء الأشخاص ليقولوا لهؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين لا يتخلون عن
[موسيقى]